stephanie's in rochester new york hi
stephanie welcome to the ramsay show
hi how are you better than i deserve
what's up in your world
um well my husband and i are trying to
decide if
um we should purchase a used vehicle or
if we should
um keep a vehicle that needs to be
repaired
um what baby step are you in we're in
baby step two
okay why would you what's the repair
uh it's it's like a muffler issue
but it's like um leaking uh
fumes into the car and they said it's
gonna cost about eight hundred dollars
what's your car worth uh
i think it's about maybe like 2500
um with with needing to take 800
to fix a muffler um it's the repair shop
i know what i mean just an independent
repair shop or a muffler shop or the
dealer
uh it's an independent like car repair
shop have you gotten other quotes
no okay that's first clue
um you you always get more than one
quote when something seems weird because
this sounds a little weird
that sounds super expensive for a
muffler issue and i don't know cars
stephanie at all but that just sounds
expensive i thought so too but
i mean i might be missing part of it
yeah you could be
and we could be too but it's worth
checking on further because
it could be 400 which changes the
conversation doesn't it
yeah you wouldn't even been calling
issue to fix the car
800 puts it on the bubble so how much do
you have in savings
we have five thousand dollars right now
and we're expecting to get about 2500
back from our taxes um
and i've kind of been nervous about
putting that toward our debt because of
our cars and not knowing
they're both kind of older higher
mileage cars
and i was thinking you know within the
next year or so we might need to replace
them but i don't know if it's smart to
just
hold on to that money in case something
happened to the car or just
not worry about it pay down the debt and
then you know
well you're you're working your plan if
you're working our plan if you're
working our plan
you apply the money towards the debt
yeah
even even if your car is like possibly
going to be breaking down
honey cars are all possibly going to be
breaking down
every one of them every car in this
parking lot is possibly breaking down
at any moment how much debt do you have
um
ten thousand seven hundred fifty dollars
and what's your household income
about forty two thousand so i mean with
the money that you have and the money
that you're expecting to get
you just you could be debt-free soon
yeah if you quit holding onto your
muffler money
you know i i don't want you to die from
carbon monoxide poisoning so i do want
you get this fixed
and get some more bids on it and find
out how dangerous it is or does it just
stink and so on
and you know so when we were going broke
i mean we were coming out of going broke
and trying to dig our way out doing what
you're doing and we were so broke we
couldn't pay attention and we were
scared just like you are
i was driving a car that the
transmission
main seal busted on it now let me tell
you what that means
that means the transmission fluid leaks
out of the transmission you know where
it goes
onto the muffler and you know what it
does it smokes
like a james bond car or something it's
put out a smoke screen behind me it
looked like a movie
and i had to put transmissional fluid in
the thing almost every three days just
to keep it running
but i just kept pouring transmission
fluid in it and smoking up the neighbors
and um and finally finally we got the
other side of it and i got the money to
fix the stupid car after i got the debts
cleaned up
and uh but i limped through because i
had to
change my direction and that's what i
want you to do i don't want you to do
something that's dangerous the car i was
driving wasn't dangerous it just stunk
but uh and the neighbors thought it's
funny and it's a funny story now it
wasn't funny that it was embarrassing as
crap
but uh but i did drive that old beat up
thing and i i got through
and now i drive whatever the flip i want
to drive because i've got the money now
and the reason i got the money
is i i didn't keep falling back into the
same trap
my 1996 jeep grand cherokee dave it's
crap like a go-kart it smells well you
probably
hauled goats around in it because you
had goats i actually did but that's
not smell like no it stunk like that
that that oil smell like a go-kart like
if you were at the go-kart races
i prayed that thing back to life more
times than i can count
like great prayed it back to life cars
don't have a soul
that didn't happen that didn't happen
you cannot lay hands on lazarus the
cheap
well the jeep came back to life you take
that up with god himself
that jeep came back to life when i
prayed
but you're right it's like it's
embarrassing for a season and then you
get through that season and she's not
even that far i mean we're talking 7400
she's so close yeah she's 7 500 bucks
and out of 10
000 and just boom you're gonna be right
there we could see this
but you're gonna have to change your
focus on what what what do you believe
in
what do you believe is gonna take you to
the next five years keeping this money
in the account limping along with these
old cars and
and limping out of that or busting
through kiddo
our suggestion is bust through you're
gonna make a decision now what do you
believe in
and all of us let me tell you for a
whole bunch of us a whole bunch of you
listening
that are out of debt and have become
everyday millionaires me and christy
we've all driven that crappy car that
was so crappy that you had to give it a
name
old blue bertha whatever her name was
i don't know why they get female names
not the david nobody nobody names it
george take it easy they always give
them negative female names
henrietta i don't know but you got to
give them a name
that you know and if you if you hadn't
been through that then you don't know
what that poor lady's facing but we're
with you stephanie you can do this